[Music]
all right
1800
we're gonna go with our trusty
one e4
okay so as far as i remember we haven't
faced the karo khan too many times
and
there are gazillion setups that you can
choose against the karakan it actually
doesn't matter as much what setup you
choose
what matters more is that you know it
well
uh we have i think played the fantasy
uh the only time that we faced the car
we played the fantasy let's repeat it
and let's see how it holds up at this
level that's the move f2 f3 which
doesn't have the greatest reputation but
in my opinion very undeservedly so an
incredibly tricky line
that can lead to quick victories if
black is not very precise okay so we
have a train on e4 now e5 and that is
the main line
this is a classic idea you don't want to
take on e5 because there's a super nasty
check on h4 so what you want to do here
and you also don't want to go c3 because
that doesn't stop the check on h4 so you
want to play this almost vienna style
you go knight f3 the fantasy is very
annoying for karakon players who often
like a more
quiet positional game and that is one
very good way of choosing openings as
you choose lines that are
practically speaking very unpleasant to
face
and also our theoretically demanding
bishop g4
the main move
um and that's that is a good line bishop
g4 is a good move so it pins the knight
and again
we don't want to play d takes e5 that's
not in the spirit of the
of the opening to allow the queen trade
and then black is going to win back the
pawn does anybody know what the correct
move is here with white
so it's bishop yeah very good so the
correct move is bishop c4 aiming at f7
and there's an obvious tactical threat
of bishop takes f7 and knight takes c5
the classic idea
now you might look at this and say wait
a moment what if black takes the knight
well don't miss the forest for the trees
if black takes the knight you take back
and you have a massive attack on the f7
pawn bishop takes f3 is a terrible move
here and black once again it has to be
very precise
yes precisely exactly
reminds me of michael tall well this is
a a very well known line i didn't invent
this fetty bitty those people watching
on youtube once this comes out yeah if
anybody knows what the drink is
you get a
a million dollars
okay knight f6
and that's immediately a blunder and
this is honestly why
you choose lines based on
what your opponent is going to
not like to face i i really find it odd
that
he thought for a while so he must have
seen the idea of bishop f7 probably what
happened is that you didn't realize that
after knight takes e5 check
we're attacking the bishop with two
different pieces and it's only going to
be defended by one so we obviously still
have bishop takes f7 check and it's
quite crushing now the move is knight d7
you have to know 97 to cover the e5
square
okay so
he's going for this but now we're two
pawns up
the king is in shambles we're completely
winning right out of the opening like
eight moves in this isn't even
borderline winning this is just winning
two pawns up it could become one if
knight takes c4 happens but
we've got mating ideas on the b3 g8
diagonal or i guess a2 g8 diagonal
technically
so we have these kinds of ideas
coupled with the idea of attacking down
the f-file i just don't see black
surviving this more than a couple more
moves no it's not alcoholic it's not
absinthe
knight d7
that's about as good of a move as any
but it leaves us with our center intact
i feel like we can decide here between
the materialistic approach which is
knight c3 in order to protect e4 but we
don't really have to do that we can also
just castle
i mean do we really care about the c4
problem what we care about a lot more
is the open f file and activating our
pieces quickly so
largely it's a matter of taste
we even yeah we do have the move c3
threatening queen b3 but that's a little
i don't love c3
because it doesn't address
well maybe i actually do like c3 that's
a very interesting move the problem
let's say c3 black goes h6 though
i feel like you're over relying on a
gimmicky
threat
and you're under emphasizing development
i think that square should be reserved
for the night so i'm having a hard time
deciding between castles and knight c3
let's just go knight c3 i feel like
that's
just probably simpler
it's probably simpler to keep the two
extra puns and we'll castle on the next
move but yeah don't fall for one move
itis in these positions that's actually
very very common type of mistake not a
specific mistake type of mistake where
you see a
mating pattern that kind of looks cool
and you get very excited and you don't
ask yourself whether your opponent can
actually stop the threat you think oh c3
queen b3 i'm a genius but
you know that comes at a cost
and now of course we castle
now of course we castle not fearing
bishop takes c3 and knight takes d4
because without the dark scored bishop
in addition to everything that we've
already pointed out the dark squares are
also going to be really weak so that i
think is going to be the last straw
utterly that's really overwhelming this
is honestly this he's he's
queen c7
okay
i think it time has come for us to sort
of step on the gas pedal
what does that mean
what there's a move here that to me
looks incredibly good
it's it's good no matter how you look at
it it's just it's it it's quite natural
in my opinion i think some of you
probably are contemplating bishop f4
i know some of you are thinking about
that but i don't like bishop f4 as much
because that blocks the f file
again
resisting the temptation to just make a
move because it threatens the opponent's
queen yeah the best best move i think is
e5
the idea is to get the knight off of f6
in fact you control the f6 square
so that after knight takes you for queen
takes you for you're threatening queen
e6 checkmate and black cannot put
anything in the way of the rook and
we're using our center to dislodge
black's only remaining defender
and
this is
a disaster for black queen d3
was proposed as well oh intending queen
c4 yeah no that was good too
okay well that was
obviously pretty one-sided but you know
blah good that you lost the game here
and not you know in some rated game well
i guess it is rated but you get it back
and it's uh
it's um
very important to know the fantasy
it's not common at an 1800 level at all
it's really not coming at any level but
that's also what makes it such a
dangerous weapon but you i assume you
missed did you see the threat of bishop
takes f7 no it's okay
if you i mean
if you're not familiar with this line
it's not easy to figure out
exactly what you should do but i'm
curious if you saw bishop f7 or you
missed it entirely
what was the logic behind that f6 i saw
it but didn't realize oh yeah i think
you saw but didn't realize that the
knight back back attacks the bishop
yeah the move here is knight d7 only
move
and then the line continues so white
castles it looks very scary for black
but black is in time to put the knight
on f6 covering the rook
and in this position
white generally goes c2 c3 why not queen
f6
well because you don't want to do with
your queen what you can do with your
knight right queen f6 puts the queen
right on the rook's x-ray
and creates tactical potential with
discovery
obviously white would have to i think
the move h3 here is very strong for
white because if you take this shows you
why you don't want to have a queen doing
the job of a knight because you have to
move the queen away and you lose f7
if you move h5 then you run into g4
yeah so
you develop your knight white ghost c3
intending queen b3 this time queen b3
actually is a good idea because it
creates both a battery and an attack on
b7
and um bishop d6
and you get this very complicated
position with a lot going on in the
center
and you can do some research on your own
if you want to know more about this
white is bishop g5 white also has
queen b3
and queen b3 black castles and then
taking this pawn is very very dangerous
for white because white is very
underdeveloped so
the bottom line is that black has many
good systems against the fantasy but
all of them lead to
really sharp positions that uh that are
not to the liking of the average karo
khan player
in terms of what black's other
options are if you're a car con player
queen b6 is a relatively recent move
that
uh that some grand grandmasters like to
play the point is to put immediate
pressure on d4 and there's this idea
it's not a great line but i like to do
this online move e5 here
d5 bishop c5
and again if white is not careful this
could get really really
spicy knight g2 gets checkmated on the
dark squares
so white
needs to know the move knight a4
and now
this is a very classic
way of dealing with this battery you
have to make sure that the e3 square is
protected by the way anytime you do this
this is often missed at lower levels
this particular check mating mechanism
now here obviously you have a bishop
that guards e3
so if black does this he has to move his
queen to d4
and then you get a very interesting end
game that i've had online a couple of
times white is better
but white has to know you know a bunch
of accurate moves here in a bunch of
theory
paris sounds pretty good
okay youtube people there's like a
separate conversation going on in the
twitch that has
nothing to do with the speed run
um
so that's one line
you can also play e6 which is a little
bit passive but also very reputable
reputable system knight t3 bishop before
resembles a win-hour french it's got a
lot of similarities
and uh
that's that's about it i mean i would
definitely do some research if you're on
the black
side of the karaoke
and you want to know know it well
other than that yeah once once bishop f7
happens the game is over
you take the bishop
had black taken the pawn
i mean white castles
i see a couple of online games
continuing 97 and now queen d3 looks
crushing
now this threatens queen b3 and it
attacks the knight so it's a
a fork
and and there's very little to talk
about here
yeah a pretty short short but sweet game
thank you blood latte appreciate you um
volunteering to play
is queen f3 not good no queen f3 is also
good of course no queen f3 all so good
doesn't shouldn't even matter
yeah it's just chess you know like you
miss one little tactic and that's it the
game is over chess brother the 37 months
you're good that was uh plenty
instructive
all right guys 2 30 am i i gotta i gotta
hit the bed i'm i've got to be up in
five hours so
if you want good commentary in the
morning gotta give me a little time i
know that was a short game but we'll
definitely
definitely try to put in a stream
tomorrow
and uh thank you everybody for the
ridiculous support chef jam
[Music]
you